[Music]
hmm
is
[Music]
i'm marcus smith creative director of
ratchet and clank rift apart
a brand new full-length ratchet and
clank adventure built from the ground up
for the playstation
5 console today we're going to introduce
you to some of the gameplay
characters and arsenal of rift apart
whether you've played every game since
ratchet clank's debut
or you're brand new to the series rift
apart is a standalone adventure that you
won't want to miss
let's get into it oh
clank clank
[Music]
halambax what is
this place
where are you clank maybe someone around
here has seen him
have any of you seen a little grey robot
anywhere green eyes
red antenna very charming
[Music]
ratchet has been separated from his best
friend and partner clank
and is now in a new dimension and a
mysterious urban sprawl
called nefarious city
please let there be good news behind
here
ratchet quickly finds out that in this
dimension dr nefarious is a much more
capable
villain welcome to the nefarious city
bazaar
please remember to thank our marvelous
emperor
before during and after making your
purchase
emperor does that mean there are two
nefariouses now
clank first nefarious later maybe he's
in this bazaar
thanks to the new hardware the worlds in
rift apart are more beautiful than ever
cities are full of life with traffic and
civilians milling about
everywhere rift apart is full of the
unexpected
characters in this new dimension are not
always the same as they were in ratchet
and clank's dimension ratchet comes
across miss zercon
the weapon vendor in rift apart wait a
second
you forgot your order we'll come right
in
mr khan will sell you weapons but you
gotta be less conspicuous
or the resistance will not last
the resistance
[Music]
oh apologies sugar
miss zerkon is still new to all of this
[Music]
espionage
flank has been taken by a mysterious new
lombax
named rivet clank
i need to go after that ship how can i
get off planet
it's a test only royal starships are
allowed to leave
anything else
phantom can help just follow the beat to
club nefarious and you will
find him club nefarious got it oh and
nice work secret agent zircon
this is so exciting
club nefarious shouldn't be hard to miss
better look around
[Music]
huh
sounds like a club all right
[Applause]
operations
[Music]
[Applause]
once ratchet finds phantom he learns a
couple of new moves
[Music]
one of the focal points of gameplay in
rift apart is increased mobility
ratchet can now dash and wall run to
traverse levels
this focus on mobility allows players to
chain moves together to create
exhilarating humps
now let's jump into combat nefarious day
spa
if you can distract these troopers i'll
hack the fairies as propaganda blimp and
give this city
a message it'll never forget
looks easy enough
dashing allows you to evade attacks or
gain strategic advantages
enemies can't hit what doesn't
momentarily exist
dimensional tears in the world allow you
to use the rift tether
another new traversal mechanic to
instantly pull yourself across
battlefields to escape or flank enemies
weapons in rift apart utilize the power
of the dual sense wireless controllers
adaptive triggers and haptic feedback to
allow players to really feel the power
of their arsenal
for example with the burst pistol
players can pull back the trigger
part way to peck out accurately placed
single shots
but pulling the trigger fully unleashes
a rapid fire spread that covers more
area
in either case players will feel each
shot burst from the weapon and connect
with enemy
with the enforcer players can pull the
trigger down halfway to fire a single
barrel
reducing time between reloads or pull
the trigger fully
and unleash both barrels with a
devastating close range attack
thanks to the haptics the player will
feel the power of their shots through
their hands
let's move ahead a little bit
as ratchet attempts to follow rivet and
clank he encounters a nefarious
juggernaut
where did you even come from
during this fight more dimensional chaos
ensues
thanks to the power of the ssd we can
near instantly teleport players to
completely different locations
this isn't some small arena being loaded
but the entire level
from a different planet
let's jump over and see what's going on
with rivet and clank
as you may have guessed rivet is a brand
new playable character in the series
where are you taking me i was gonna take
you to my hideout
but first i gotta rescue my friends at
their gelatonium factory
rift apart includes several alternate
dimension versions of classic planets
from past games
did we mention how stunning and alive
our worlds are
thanks to the power of the ps5 and the
3d audio we've been able to create
alien planets with an immersive density
like never before
let's check it out speedles yeah that's
why i'm gonna ride one
as soon as i can get close enough back
to miss zircon the weapons vendor
this wasn't what was in my account last
time oh
that is because i added our mutual
friend on nefarious city
okay in rift apart you get to play with
an explosive new arsenal
as well as a few returning classics
[Music]
sweet things
[Music]
here's another example of how we're
using the dual sense with the topiary
sprinkler
players will feel resistance in the
trigger as they prepare a throw of this
garden grenade
once on the ground and spitting out its
rapid growth plant fertilizer
players will also feel when enemies have
been topiaried
and are ready to be trimmed down
it appears some dimensional distortion
is emanating from that cave
in addition to rift tethering and
dimensional shifts there are also many
pocket dimensions scattered throughout
the game
and the last speedle runs into that rift
thingy interesting you must have a rift
tether in your glove
too
all right smartybot what is this place i
am a dimensional pocket
perhaps a symptom of the dimensionator's
destruction
how do you come up with this stuff
hey it's maynard the mortz's helper bot
must have wandered in through the rift
somehow
there is the speedle
[Music]
no no don't hide ah hitting its nest
might get its attention hello there
[Music]
oh dear
maybe maynard
[Music]
[Applause]
now if we can get away from this acid
come on maynard
let's find the morts riding speedls is
one way of traversing sargasso's acid
swamps
and to do so quickly excuse me
look out i got it i got it
see sometimes i don't crash
across dimensions just to get stopped by
some fuzz balls
so you got like nine and a half seconds
to tell us where they're at
one hang on there now
if you watched our previous gameplay
demo you may recognize the goons for
less
this rebranded gang has been hired by dr
nefarious to attack ratchet and clank
and are now also trapped in rivets
dimension
here's another new weapon the shatter
bomb is a frag type grenade that deals a
lot of damage to your foes
with haptic feedback each explosion
feels incredibly impactful
where are these coming from perhaps they
were sucked through the dimensional
vortex as well
in my head is freaking hard
this is just a small taste of some of
the early gameplay in rift apart
but there is so much more we have open
areas to explore
dimensional clank puzzles
glitch challenges
[Music]
arena challenges
[Music]
aerial combat
[Music]
gold bolts to collect pocket dimensions
to explore
armor to obtain and use in the first
ever ratchet and clank photo mode
and giving more people access to playing
our games is always important to us
as such rift apart will offer a slew of
accessibility options
we'll reveal more about this soon
experience rift departs new planets
weapons intense high action combat and
near instant load times
all with some of the best visuals we've
ever created
these ribs are getting out of hand on
behalf of all of us at insomniac games
thank you for watching
we'll see you in the omniverse on june
11th
playstation